here's Anna Navarro saying how Trump is
worse than DeSantis I live in Florida
and uh as many issues as I have with the
Sanders I don't think it's the same
thing because I don't think DeSantis has
been involved in promoting a coup uh
against America and in being part of the
organization so I do not yet well so
okay when he does then I'll have that
issue with him but until now I don't
think I I think I think Donald Trump is
in a class all by himself thank God
thank God there's only one Donald Trump
so there's something so interesting
going on here first off that okay Anna
and I'm told again that I live fairly
close to Hannah Navarro so I'm going to
see her one day while I'm walking Clyde
and he has uh the scent of the view
women on him and it's like what he does
I don't know what can I I can't stop him
how he got to send to the view ladies I
can't I can't tell you super deal but
Anna what she's saying there is sort of
interesting so Donald Trump of course
Donald Trump caused a coup now let's
remember over the coup which had no
leader it had no plans they brought no
weapons the officers at the Capitol let
everybody in there were some grandmas
that took selfies a bunch of that kind
of stuff and then yes a few a few bad
people were there of course too who were
being held on trial indefinitely and a
whole bunch of other stuff uh I you know
isolated uh punishment and all that okay
fine but Joy's response to he hasn't
started a coup not yet that's what Joy
said not yet so you can see what they're
doing Trump right now still looms the
largest right he's the orangest he's the
biggest his hair is the craziest he's
the number one threat but you can see
what they will do to DeSantis and I
think this is the key thing for anyone
who is not a woke lefty or a Democrat
anyone who's willing to go Against the
Machine what they did to Donald Trump
they will do to you and what I mean by
that actually is not just anyone who's
in politics if whatever it is that you
do in your life if you stand up to the
thing they will throw everything they
got at you that's what cancel culture is
all about that's what this fear is all
about that's what this revolutionary I
would say this counter-revolution
against their Revolution is all about so
DeSantis will be painted as he's just as
bad as Trump but he's more competent so
he's even worse that's the new thing the
New Yorker magazine just did a big piece
on that that he's got all of the
policies of trump but he knows how to
staff and he knows how to actually
execute Trump is just shooting from the
hip doesn't really know what he's doing
so he's even worse so that's going to be
a sort of blend that we're going to
constantly see there and then of course
the other thing that they're going to
constantly be pushing is Liz Cheney
because there is nothing that the media
loves more than a pet Republican a
republican who will go on television to
tell you how bad Republicans are and who
never accomplishes nor conserves
anything uh and this is interesting a
little more from The View man we're
really putting them through it today I
feel like I owe you guys a drink this is
this Charlemagne the God guy I can't
call him that I can't I call him that so
when I can't call someone else God it's
blasphemy man so apparently his name is
Leonard mcelvey okay so some people call
him Charlemagne the God his name's
Leonard okay
it's cool fine so here's Leonard on The
View uh and they're asking him about
about Liz Cheney okay we were talking
about politics and we were talking about
Liz Cheney and there's some people like
me who see her as a profile and courage
as a historical figure as somebody who's
Cheney yes how do you see her
not none of those things I mean I don't
I don't I mean that's a broad question
how do I fear like yeah because some
people see her as a hero in today's
politics no some people see her as a
zero well she's standing up to people
who say that the bar was actually pretty
low I mean she was stolen yeah but she
was complicit for four years I mean when
you ride with uh Donald Trump on damn
near everything for four years I don't
think you can be considered a hero all
right so Leonard look I'm not really
into what you're saying there either
it's just interesting to watch this it's
like I don't know wants him to be like
yes Trump's the worst Liz Cheney's the
worst and he's like wait a minute but
Liz kind of like Trump so I don't know
about that also I don't know what
Leonard's talking about like what she
ran you know she was with Trump she rode
with Trump for four years and boy what
what happened well we had no Wars
remember that no war thing that was
pretty good we had lowest all-time uh
Black and Latino unemployment that was
pretty good remember that that was
pretty good he was the first first term
president to ever come in uh for
marriage equality that seemed pretty
good uh things were going quite well you
could go to creightonbarrel.com and
order a chair that would come in the
same calendar year that was pretty good
uh so it's just sort of funny watching
these people operate but there's nothing
more that people like Anna Navarro sort
of the just these generic you know
rotating casts of nothingness people
that are in mainstream media there's
nothing more than they love than that
pet Republican who goes on these shows
says what they want they get a cookie
they get pat on the head sometimes on
the butt and they get out of there